it will be hey
i've let my son who's 10 watch austin
powers with guidance and do a lot of
it and some of the parts
right
but for the most part they don't really
watch it i don't watch it i have a real
separation of church at state
something else mike's kids likely won't
see his new r-rated netflix series the
pentavarus where were you born well
actually i was born in toronto the
comedian plays multiple characters
including a canadian journalist who
finds himself involved in a mission that
could possibly save the world from a
secret society i'm very proud of being
canadian i've often said
if i wasn't actually canadian i would
want to be canadian i'm being sent to
dubrovnik i repeat
sent to dubrovnik what's the broadneck
is that a euphemism for being probed in
your no-no hole
i can't think of a lot of
other actors that can do what you do
where you take on all these characters
but you become these characters not just
you putting on a costume and you see
mike mars underneath it's like you are
who you are playing when do you become
that person i get warmed up in the chair
the makeup chair is my time
to get warmed up i learned this from
martin short
who said that when he did sctv
the mirror
had the outside trick the inside is the
illuminati reel yes
both beyonce and jay zed are part of it
sadly i have to stay in character all
day i have such a thick scar-bro accent
i mean you you will need a blowtorch and
a crowbar to get this accent off me i
will talk like this
forever anytime i do something i have to
stay
in the accent i'm doing i haven't had
this much fun since i was at a nudist
colony and accidentally backed into a
meat thermometer